FIRST, LESSONS LEARNED.
THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT’S
ANGLE.
THIS HAS BEEN A VERY DIFFICULT
TIME FOR ALL OF US IN AMERICA.
WE KNOW THIS PANDEMIC HAS LED TO
MASSIVE ECONOMIC LOSSES AND
DISRUPTIONS TO YOUR DAILY LIFE,
ALL OF OUR DAILY LIVES.
NOW WE HAVE LOST MORE THAN 80
AMERICANS NOW TO THIS DISEASE.
OVER 4500 ARE INFECTED.
THOSE NUMBERS WILL INCREASE AS
MORE TESTING BECOMES AVAILABLE.
THE DOW JONES HAD THE WORST DAY
IN ITS HISTORY, DROPPING ALMOST
3,000 POINTS.
THAT IS DESPITE THE FED SLASHING
INTEREST RATES TO NEAR ZERO.
THE PHRASE SOCIAL DISTANCING IS
NOW BURNED INTO OUR
CONSCIOUSNESS.
WE WILL NEVER FORGET THAT ONE.
AND MOST OF THE COUNTRY IS
SEEING SCHOOL SHUTTER.
WE WORKING PARENTS HAVE
CHILD CARE ISSUES ON TOP OF ALL
THE OTHER PROBLEMS WE ARE
DEALING WITH.
PARENTS WHO LIVE PAYCHECK TO
PAYCHECK, THEY CAN’T AFFORD
CHILD CARE.
>> IS THIS THE NEW NORMAL UNTIL
THE HEIGHT OF THE SUMMER?
>> WE WILL SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
THEY THINK AUGUST, COULD BE
JULY, COULD BE LONGER THAN THAT.
>> Laura: WHILE THE NEW
FEDERAL GUIDELINES ABOUT PUBLIC
GATHERINGS SHOULD BE ABIDED BY
OF COURSE, TAKEN EXTREMELY
SERIOUSLY, WE’LL HAVE TO TAKE
THEM SERIOUSLY.
WE MUST NOT ALLOW THIS TO BECOME
THE NEW NORMAL.
ONCE WE REACH THE OTHER SIDE OF
THIS CURRENT CRISIS.
WE HAVE HEARD THAT PHRASE, NEW
NORMAL, A LOT TODAY.
TONIGHT I’M SAYING THAT IF WE
LEARN CORRECT LESSONS FROM ALL
OF THIS, IN THE FUTURE WE BOTH
CAN KEEP OUR PEOPLE SAFE AND
PRESERVE OUR FREEDOM.
OUR WAY OF LIFE.
AND YES, OUR FREE MARKET.
A VIRUS OR ANYTHING FOR THAT
MATTER THAT OCCURS IN ANOTHER
COUNTRY SHOULD NOT BE ALLOWED TO
COLLAPSE OUR ECONOMY AND
COMPLETELY OFFEND OUR WAY OF
LIFE.
THE FREEDOMS GUARANTEED UNDER
OUR CONSTITUTION CANNOT BE
GUTTED EVERY TIME ANY COUNTRY
ACTS NEGLIGENTLY OR RECKLESSLY,
INCLUDING A COUNTRY LIKE CHINA.
WHAT IF THIS VIRUS OR ANOTHER
ONE POPS UP AGAIN IN THE FALL?
ARE WE ALL GOING TO BE TOLD TO
SHELTER IN PLACE FOR ANOTHER
LONG PERIOD OF TIME?
15 DAYS, MAYBE A MONTH NEXT
TIME?
DOES THAT MEAN WE ARE GOING TO
CLOSE PUBLIC SCHOOLS AGAIN?
ALL SCHOOLS?
WHAT WAS HE A GROCERY STORE
PANIC BUYING RESUME?
CITYWIDE CURFEWS, DELAYED
ELECTIONS.
IF THIS BECOMES THE NEW NORMAL
AFTER WE DEAL WITH THIS VIRUS
AND WE HAVE TO DEAL WITH THIS
NOW, WILL WE CEASE TO BE THE
AMERICA WE KNOW AND LOVE?
THERE ARE THE OBVIOUS SHORT-TERM
LESSONS LIKE WASHING YOUR HANDS,
WIPING DOWN YOUR BAGS, NO
COUGHING OTHER PEOPLE’S FACES
WHICH WE ALREADY KNEW THAT BUT
APPARENTLY WE DIDN’T AND WE KNOW
IT NOW.
IF WE DON’T LEARN THE RIGHT
LONG-TERM LESSONS, WE COULD FACE
A RECURRING CYCLE OF MISERY AND
SHUTDOWNS WHEN SOMETHING HAPPENS
IT’S REALLY BAD IN ANOTHER
COUNTRY.
HERE ARE A FEW OF THE IMPORTANT
LESSONS TO PREVENT THIS
NIGHTMARE FROM HAPPENING AGAIN.
THIS GOES FAR BEYOND THE GET
TOUGH CHINA POLICY OF THIS
ADMINISTRATION.
WE NEED TO MOVE TO GET INTO A
REAL APPROACH TO CHINA.
FOR TWO DECADES I’VE BEEN ON TV
AND IN THE PRINT MEDIA WITH ONLY
A HANDFUL OF OTHERS WARNING
ABOUT THE DANGERS OF
GLOBALIZATION TO OUR WORKERS, TO
OUR CORE INDUSTRIES.
OUR NATIONAL SECURITY.
NOW OUR NATIONAL HEALTH IS ON
THE LINE TOO WITH GLOBALIZATION.
WHAT DID THEY CALL US THEN?
THEY CALLED US ISOLATIONIST.
I SAY IT’S BETTER TO BE CALLED
AN ISOLATIONIST THAN TO BE
FORCED TO ISOLATE AT HOME.
LAST WEEK, CHINESE OFFICIALS
HINTED THAT THEY COULD CUT OFF
ALL ANTIBIOTICS TO THE
UNITED STATES.
LAST WEEK EUROPEAN COUNTRIES
BEGAN BANNING EXPORTS OF KEY
MEDICAL SUPPLIES USED TO COMBAT
COVID-19.
SMART NATIONS KNOW IN
EMERGENCIES, THEY NEED TO
PROTECT THEIR OWN FIRST.
THE CHINESE PEOPLE LIVE UNDER AN
EVIL REGIME, AND IT SEEKS WORLD
DOMINATION.
WE CANNOT AND SHOULD NOT TRADE
AWAY OUR LIVES AND OUR
LIVELIHOOD IN RELIANCE ON THEM.
SO THAT MEANS WE HAVE TO DO
WHATEVER IT TAKES TO BRING BACK
OUR MANUFACTURING OF MEDICINES,
DRUGS, AND OTHER KEY
TECHNOLOGIES TO THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
MADE IN AMERICA, YOU BET.
MY MOM USED TO SAY IT.
WE NEED MORE MADE IN AMERICA
BACK IN THE 1970s AND BOY, DO
WE NEED THAT KIND OF APPROACH
NOW.
THANKFULLY THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION SEEMS TO BE
TAKING THIS LESSON TO HEART.
>> THE PRESIDENT PERSONALLY
ASKED ME TO MOVE QUICKLY ON THIS
ISSUE.
THE VA, HHS AND THE DEPARTMENT
OF DEFENSE BY A MACK A TON OF
MEDICINES, MEDICAL SUPPLIES AND
EQUIPMENT.
WE NEED TO HAVE THEM BUY THAT
FROM AMERICAN PRODUCERS ON
AMERICAN-STYLE’STOIL.
>> Laura: SOMEONE SAYS PRICES
FOR GOODS WILL GO UP IF WE BRING
THIS MANUFACTURING BACK, REMIND
THEM ABOUT THE TRILLION SET UP
AND WIPED OUT IN THE LAST TWO
WEEKS.
BECAUSE OF THE CORONAVIRUS.
IT’S A HUGE, HUGE SERIES OF
LOSSES FOR AMERICAN FAMILIES IN
AMERICAN BUSINESS.
LESSON NUMBER TWO.
WE CAN NO LONGER ALLOW THE
RABBIT LEFT IN AMERICA OR GREEDY
BUSINESSES IN THE IS IN THIS
COMMUNITY TO RUN OUR BORDER AND
IMMIGRATION POLICY.
TODAY REPORTERS WERE ASKING
QUESTIONS ABOUT WHEN ARE WE
GOING TO SHUT THE NORTHERN
BORDER.
WHAT ARE WE GOING TO DO WITH
CANADA?
EVEN GUATEMALA AND MEXICO ARE
SEEING MY BORDER ENFORCEMENT AND
BORDER HEALTH SCREENING ARE
REALLY IMPORTANT NOW.
THE WISDOM OF TRUMP.
PEOPLE ARE KIND OF CATCHING ON.
WHEN WE DID ANGLE SEGMENTS OF
THE LAST TWO YEARS ABOUT THE
RISE OF TV AND OTHER DISEASES
COMING ACROSS OUR SOUTHERN
BORDER, WE WERE VILIFIED, AS
WERE OTHERS, AS ANTI-IMMIGRANTS.
THAT CRITICISM WAS A VICIOUS
LIE.
WE WERE BEING PRO-AMERICAN.
JUST LIKE EVERYONE WHO’S URGING
STRONG ACTION NOW ON FOUR
ENTRIES COMING INTO THE
UNITED STATES.
THEY ARE WORRIED ABOUT AMERICA.
SO ARE WE.
EVERYONE EXCEPT JOE BIDEN.
>> THE FIRST 100 DAYS OF MY TO
ADMINISTRATION, NO ONE, NO ONE
WILL BE DEPORTED AT ALL.
>> Laura: WITH THAT ANSWER
LAST NIGHT, HOW CAN ANYONE THINK
THAT BIDEN WOULD BE TOUGHER THAN
TRUMP IN INSTITUTING STRONG
MEASURES AGAINST COVID-19?
LESSON NUMBER THREE.
HEALTH SCREENINGS MUST BE
INSTITUTED AT ALL U.S. ENTRY
POINTS.
A GOOD FRIEND TEXTED ME LAST
NIGHT WHO WAS TRAVELING FROM
KURDISTAN TRYING TO GET BACK IN
THE UNITED STATES AND THIS WAS
HIS TEXT.
"SCREENING BEFORE U.S. FLIGHTS
IS VERY LONG BUT RIDICULOUS.
THEY DIDN’T ASK ANY QUESTIONS OR
CHECK TEMP.
HERE THEY CHECKED TEMPERATURE ON
THE PLANE WITH THERMAL VISOR AND
THEN AGAIN AT THE AIRPORT."
APPARENTLY WE HAVE IMPROVED AND
ARE BEEFING UP SCREENING TO SOME
EXTENT.
THIS HAS TO BE DONE AT LEAST
FROM CHINA AND EUROPE NOW ON A
PERMANENT BASIS GOING FORWARD.
I WAS THINKING, IF WE CAN DO
FACIAL RECOGNITION TO CATCH
TERRORISTS AND OTHER CRIMINALS
TRYING TO COME THROUGH OUR PORTS
OF ENTRY NOW WHICH WE CAN,
SURELY WE CAN SCREEN AT LEAST
SOMEWHAT FOR DISEASE AND ILLNESS
GOING FORWARD.
AGAIN, SO WE DON’T GO THROUGH
WHAT WE ARE GOING THROUGH RIGHT
NOW AGAIN.
AMERICA WITHOUT TECHNOLOGY,
SOMEONE REMINDED ME OF THIS,
WITHOUT ANY TECHNOLOGY, WE HAD
COMMON SENSE AT THE BEGINNING OF
THE LAST CENTURY.
REMEMBER COMING THROUGH
ELLIS ISLAND?
WE HAD PEOPLE COMPLETELY
SEPARATED FROM THE AMERICAN
POPULATION UNTIL IT WAS ASSURED
THAT THEY WEREN’T GOING TO BRING
DISEASE INTO THE UNITED STATES.
IN THE EARLY 1900s.
WE DID IT THEN.
WE CAN FIGURE OUT A WAY TO DO IT
EFFICIENTLY NOW.
I SAY ALL OF THIS TONIGHT NOT
BECAUSE I WANT TO POINT FINGERS
ARE REHASHED.
NO, NO, NO.
BECAUSE OUR FREEDOM OF ASSEMBLY,
OUR FREEDOM OF WORSHIP, OUR
FREEDOM OF MOVEMENT, OF TRAVEL,
NONE OF THAT IS GOING TO MEAN
ANYTHING IF WE HAVE TO SHUT DOWN
OUR SOCIETY AND DESTROY OUR
ECONOMY EVERY TIME ANOTHER
HEALTH CRISIS FROM ABROAD
THREATENS TO OVERWHELM US.
SO WE HAVE TO BE THINKING NOT
ONLY HOW TO GET THROUGH THE
IMMEDIATE CRISIS WHICH THE TRUMP
TEAM IS DOING AND THEY ARE DOING
A GREAT JOB OF NOW AT THIS
POINT.
WE ALSO HAVE TO PREVENT SIMILAR
EMERGENCIES, CRISES, CHALLENGES
FROM HITTING US AND OVERWHELMING
US IN THE FUTURE.
AFTER PEARL HARBOR, WHAT DID WE
DO?
WELL, WE KNEW WE HAD TO DO
SOMETHING.
WE BUILT UP OUR MILITARY AND
HEAVY MANUFACTURING TO WIN THE
WAR.
AFTER 9/11, WE MADE SOME
MISTAKES FOR SURE.
WE HAVE TALKED ABOUT THAT BEFORE
BUT WE EXPANDED SCREENING CENTER
AIRPORT AND WE IMPROVED OUR
TERROR DATABASE.
ENTER TRACKING.
AFTER THIS NEW BATTLE IS FINALLY
WON BY US, AND RAVAGES AMERICA
WHICH IT’S DOING RIGHT NOW.
WE WILL NEED TO IMPLEMENT SOUND
AND PERMANENT POLICIES TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE DON’T EVER HAVE TO
SUFFER THROUGH THIS KIND OF
THING AGAIN.
15 DAYS FROM NOW WE ARE GOING TO
BE CLOSER TO WARM WEATHER.
THAT WE HOPE WILL DO MORE TO
STEM THE MOVEMENT OF THIS VIRUS.
WE WILL BE CLOSER TO WIDESPREAD
TESTING.
AND CLOSER TO THE CLINICAL
TRIALS AND WHAT WE WILL FIND OUT
WITH THE VACCINE TESTING.
THAT’S ALL GOOD.
AND WE HOPE THAT WE BEGIN TO SEE
THE FLATTENING OF THE INFECTIONS
CURVE.
THAT IS ESSENTIAL.
BUT WE ALSO HAVE TO BE MAKING
PREPARATIONS.
SO THAT WILL BE -- WE WILL BE IN
A MUCH BETTER POSITION TO AVOID
THIS FROM EVER HAPPENING AGAIN.
THE MEDIA, SOME HAVE BEEN
ENJOYING THIS MOMENT.
THAT HAS BROUGHT GREAT
INCONVENIENCE, DISRUPTION AND
SUFFERING.
TO AMERICAN WORKERS AND FAMILIES
LET ALONE ALL THE HEALTH
CHALLENGES, THE DEATHS AND THE
INFECTION RATE.
BECAUSE SOME PEOPLE THINK IT’S
TRUMP’S DOWNFALL AND THEY ARE
CHEERING THAT ON AS THEY DID
DURING MUELLER AND ALL THESE
OTHER CRISES.
BUT AS YOU WILL SEE LATER, THE
LEFT DOESN’T HAVE A GREAT
RESPONSE HERE.
TESTING SNAGS NOTWITHSTANDING,
TRUMP HAS MOBILIZED AN
AGGRESSIVE EFFORT TO TACKLE IT.
THE DEMOCRATS ANSWER IS USUALLY
WE SHOULD DO WHAT EUROPE DOES.
OKAY.
RIGHT NOW EUROPE IS CLOSING ITS
BORDERS.
CANADA AND OTHERS ARE CLOSING
THEIR BORDERS AS WELL.
AS I WAS TELLING YOU, EVEN
COUNTRIES LIKE KIRK TO STAND ARE
DOING THERMAL VISOR CHECKS AT
AIRPORTS.
IT’S WORTH REMEMBERING THAT WHEN
TRUMP SHUT DOWN TRAVEL FROM
CHINA, REMEMBER WHO WAS
CRITICIZING IT.
>> WE WILL NOT STOP.
TRAVEL FROM EUROPE OR ANY OTHER
PART OF THE WORLD.
WE MAY SLOW IT.
WE WILL NOT STOP IT.
THIS DISEASE COULD IMPACT EVERY
NATION AND ANY PERSON ON THE
PLANET.
>> Laura: HE WAS JUST TWEETING
THE OTHER DAY, LAST THURSDAY,
THAT WALLS WON’T STOP THE
BORDER.
ARE WE TO BELIEVE THAT BIDEN
WOULD’VE SUPPORTED TRUMP’S
MOVING MORE AGGRESSIVELY AGAINST
TRAVEL IN JANUARY?
OF COURSE NOT.
YET TRUMP’S DECISION LIKELY
SAVED THOUSANDS OF LIVES.
ANTHONY FAUCI SAID IT WAS A
CRITICAL PART OF THE
DECISION-MAKING.
NOT ONLY THAT, FOR DECADES TRUMP
HAD BEEN WARNING ABOUT CHINA’S
IMPENDING DOMINANCE IN
MANUFACTURING.
THE DEMOCRATS AND THE CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE G.O.P., THEY LAUGHED AT
HIM.
THEY LAUGHED HIM OFF AS A
CANDIDATE AND THEN THEY
DISMISSED TRUMP’S AMERICA FIRST
AGENDA DURING HIS PRESIDENCY.
WELL NOW, HOW DOES THAT LOOK
NOW?
DONALD TRUMP LOOKS PRETTY
PRESCIENT ON THAT.
WE ARE GOING TO GET THROUGH IT
WILL GET THROUGH IT TOGETHER.
LET’S MAKE SURE WE LEARN THE